the goal of this video is to get an
appreciation that you could have many in
fact you could have an infinite number
of functions that have the same limit as
x approaches infinity so if we were to
make the general statement that the
limit of some function f of x as x
approaches infinity is equal to 3. what
i want to do in this video is show some
examples of that and to show that we can
keep creating more and more examples
really an infinite number of examples
where that is going to be true
so for example we could look at this
graph over here and you in other videos
we'll think about why this is the case
but just think about what happens when
you have very very large x's when you
have very very large x's the plus 5
doesn't matter as much and so it gets
closer and closer to 3x squared over x
squared which is equal to 3. and you
could see that right over here it's
graphed in this green color and you can
see even when x is equal to 10 we're
getting awfully close to 3 right over
there let me zoom out a little bit so
you see our axes so that is 3. which let
me
draw a dotted line at the asymptote that
is y is equal to 3 and so you see
the function is getting closer and
closer as x approaches infinity but
that's not the only function that could
do that as i keep saying there's an
infinite number of functions that could
do that you could have this somewhat
wild function that involves natural logs
that too
as x approaches infinity it is getting
closer and closer to 3. it might be
getting closer to 3 at a slightly slower
rate than the one in green but we're
talking about infinity as x approaches
infinity this thing is approaching three
and as we've talked about in other
videos you could even have things that
keep oscillating around the asymptote as
long as they're getting
are as long as they're getting closer
and closer and closer to it what as x
gets larger and larger and larger so for
example that function right over there
let me zoom in so let's zoom in
when
let's say when x is equal to 14
we can see that they're all approaching
three the purple one is oscillating
around it the other two are approaching
three from below
but as we get much larger let me
actually zoom out a ways and then i'll
zoom in
so let's get to really large values
so
actually even 100 isn't even that large
if we're thinking about infinity
even a trillion wouldn't be that large
if we're thinking about infinity but
let's go to 200
200 is much larger than the numbers
we've been looking at and let me zoom in
when x is equal to 200 and you can see
we'd have we have to zoom in and awfully
lot an awful lot just to even see that
the graphs still aren't quite
stabilized around the asymptote that
they are a little bit different than the
asymptote i am really zoomed in i mean
look at the scale this is each of these
are now a hundredth each square and so
we've gotten much much much closer to
the asymptote in fact the green function
we still can't tell the difference you
can see the calculation this is up to
three or four decimal places we're
getting awfully close to three now but
we aren't there so the green functions
got there the fastest is an argument but
the whole point of this is to emphasize
the fact
that there's an infinite number of
functions for which you could make the
statement that we made that the limit of
the function as x approaches infinity in
this case we said that limit is going to
be equal to three and i just picked
three arbitrarily this could be true for
any
for any function and i'm trying to i
didn't realize how much i had zoomed in
so let me now go back to the origin
where we had our original expression
so there we have it maybe i could zoom
in this way
so there you have it
limit of any of these as x approaches
infinity is equal to 3.